2019 brought us Ukraine Gate a dancing
Sean Spicer and I promised not to show
you that video I promise the end of the
game of Thrones and liberal tyranny on
campuses across the country here to take
us through it all is Charlie Kirk
Turning Point USA founder and author of
an upcoming book the mega doctoral this
one's going to be good you're gonna want
to get this one charlie I want to start
with one of the most egregious examples
of conservatives being targeted and
physically attacked for their beliefs
back in February a recruiter was
harassed and punched in the face at UC
Berkeley watch this I mean he just went
rate smack dab after him what was
happening there Charlie
that was our turning point USA group at
University of California Berkeley Hayden
Williams was out there recruiting
students now we understand we're not
going to be in the ideological majority
at University of California Berkeley but
as conservatives we still want to go out
and try to recruit any students that
might align with our belief system and
then this leftist thug Zachary greenberg
came up and smacked him in the face and
here's the sad part about this that was
in February this case has basically gone
cold he pleaded guilty the DA is still
sitting on it no trial
I've been talking to Hayden Williams and
he's just waiting for justice and I'm
afraid that there's been this pattern in
Berkeley that if you do physical
violence against conservatives such as a
professor who smacks him with a bike
lock not too long ago you might get away
with it so you saw that video a
conservative getting punched in the face
because he was trying to start a group
justice is still hanging out there I
hope the DA does the right thing in
Berkeley but I'm not too confident in
that but that was just probably one of
the most egregious examples that led to
President Trump signing the historic
executive order to protect free speech
on college campuses across the country
but I hope we can get justice for Hayden
know it was an important thing what
Donald Trump did but it's very important
what you're doing in these college
campuses and giving voice to even in a
place where they might be a minority
let's head now to North Carolina where a
conservative student this is the son of
congressman Dan Bishop he was actually
spray painted in the face
[Music]
now those activists were actually trying
to cover up ads Jack Bishop just posted
for an event featuring you Charlie
Laura spoke to him shortly after it
happened we were accosted by a few
Center a few members of the Y TSA Club
here they're merely expressing our free
speech and these these people rolled up
in a concerted intentional attempt
pre-planned attempt to censor our speech
and it's I think indicative of what's
going on and and campuses across tell me
what you learned about that case Charlie
I want your audience to think for a
second imagine if a mob of students
wearing make America great again hats
went up to a liberal student and
spray-painted that student because they
didn't like what they were saying
just imagine the outrage of course this
the media conveniently didn't cover this
despite there being video evidence of a
leftist mob that came up to him this is
comes our upcoming appearance our
turning point us a campus tour at North
Carolina State University unfortunately
again very little justice was served
because of it and the administration
didn't address that the way we would
have liked but thankfully Jack is doing
much better but as you can see many
Turning Point USA students are under
attack because their beliefs yeah and
it's amazing to be because the people
that are doing the attacking are usually
the people that are preaching the most
tolerance right it tolerance you've got
to accept everything but their end up
being the least tolerant of all of them
I got to turn now to Pennsylvania where
Tom Holman he's the former acting ice
director and a fox news contributor he
tried to speak in an event about
immigration as he served under
presidents Obama and Trump and I say
tried because well look at what happened
Charlie the campuses are the places
where we're trying to teach kids how to
think and have a civil dialogue but
what's your experience across the
country
allegedly they're supposed to be
marketplaces of ideas I mean the
students at University of Pennsylvania
they're constantly wrong but they're
never in doubt very quickly if they knew
anything about what you know Tom Holman
was trying to actually do by running ice
and running all the immigration services
they would know that went after child
sex traffickers and some of the worst
people in our society but they did what
made them feel good not what actually
would do good for society for our
country and I should clarify that Tom
Holman served under President Obama now
I want to turn to New Orleans at Tulane
University a member of your organization
actually faced an arson attack you can
see the burn marks on his door right
there what else happened that's right so
he tried to start a turning point us a
group at Tulane University and had his
dormitory tried to be firebomb now this
is one where the police intervened
quickly in the correct way and the
people that that did this were held
accountable but his public information
his private information was made public
he was doxed no student should have to
be firebombed because they're trying to
start a group on either the right or the
left but this is just another example in
2019 of the left not just disagreeing
with conservatives but targeting them
and putting them in physical danger last
one we have time for is unfortunately
happened in my home state of Utah high
school senior was arrested for releasing
pepper spray at the school to stop an
event put on by a local chapter of again
turning-point USA
yeah and Jason you know that area well
it's right in Park City the left hates
the idea that our other ideas and again
imagine if a conservative to this to
liberals it's out of control I'll tell
you what the final thing I'll say is we
will not allow the left to bully our
students or intimidate us going in 2020
it's harder than ever but we have more
resolve to continue to win on college
campuses well listen good luck to you
because going into 20 and 20 at 2020 I
think things are gonna get even more
volatile but hats off to those students
that are willing to stand up for what
they personally believe and your
organization Turning Point USA for
challenging and encouraging and inviting
conservatives to actually express their
point of view have a wonderful and happy
New Year Charlie appreciate it thank you
Jason appreciate it